you guys think that we're actually safer
because I've been thinking about this a
lot lately especially we're going to get
to Syria later but there's you know we
went to Iraq after this which had
nothing to do with 911 but it was sold
under strange pretenses we're still at
war in Afghanistan now which nobody
seems to understand this is the longest
war America has ever been in d and now
you know there's all this NSA stuff do
you think we're safer than we were
before nine eleven or is the whole thing
sort of just an illusion because we
didn't think we were in danger I guess
before then well I have to say I do
maybe it's being a slightly night but I
do think we're safer I mean I also
remember the the new year's eve before
so it was the whole millennial New
Year's Eve Len IAM New Year's Eve having
all those frightening reports I remember
being like oh it's that dude in
Afghanistan I you know I'm sure I
remember his name but I was like wait a
minute cuz he you know then the coal and
it was really like building and I
remember thinking I stayed in Brooklyn
that year because I was like you know
what I don't want to be in manhattan I
don't to be Manhattan like something's
gonna happen something's going to happen
and then of course you know then you you
know january first you just keep moving
you know what i mean but i do think
because that was so horrific and it put
everyone on guard and i'm not saying we
have to march into all these countries
and declare war that's to me like the
worst thing you can possibly do we took
all our goodwill and we set it on fire
yeah however you know just going after
and going out getting bin Laden and
going after all these extremists and
kind of it's kind of gross to say but
kind of picking them off one by one I do
feel like we have stopped you know we've
doing some like series pre-emptive work
all right after you have to try to feel
good about you cannot totally but we've
done the good with the bad I think some
of the good has come and past two years
but our first reaction was everyone one
revenge so that's why it was so much
easier for them to sell us on was that
nothing to do with what happened I mean
we had this reactionary feeling of how
dare they do this to us and whose day we
didn't had a chance to figure it out yet
but then there was a vision
our heads of whoever they was and it
still lives to this day but because of I
think the misplaced reaction the types
of things that are there are points of
government got us into it is bit there's
been an Enlightenment of just general
society to go okay uh we're not gonna do
this anymore we're no longer going to be
reactionary I mean there's a percentage
of course they're still an amount that
when they see a certain person they just
they assume things we still have that
but because of the overreaction there
had to be there's a group that pulled
back and I think it's a large group
where we see things are going way as you
as you talking about we have the NSA
issues we had now and this there's a lot
of pushback everyone's very vigilant of
their own privacy in their own lives now
in protection of their own government
for cuz there's a distrust that wasn't
there before we thought these guys were
to protect us our fingerprints yeah I
which will go directly to government
that's all please not now now we're
being taken up by things of our own
technology I mean think about 2001 I
didn't have a cell phone I mean life was
totally different so there's other
things that now that take our brains and
go well we need to uh I gotta have the
new iphone or we were thinking before oh
we gotta get revenge because there they
do this to us they an insult and take
them too far we have another push back
which i think is helpful yeah so I did
say though you know I was against every
policy George Bush possibly could come
up with but he had no choice this
country also has a real cowboy mentality
and when you come over to our turf that
type of thinking and the destruction and
what we all felt on 911 what we still
feel on every anniversary of the
absolute horror the pain of the what we
went through it there's no this country
would have been in an uproar if we
didn't go over to Afghanistan into our
America purple pal we gotta get you I
mean Iraq was an entire different
situation which was the the worst
possible choice you could make but no
one rip Republican Democrat they were
going to be four sweaters in that
presence it was going to be forced to
retaliate against it will push did some
strange things because even with
Afghanistan the idea that you gotta get
over there so you don't get them over
here
doesn't quite make sense we could have
done a lot more things that didn't have
to do with the military per se or or
traditional more yeah that's the thing
we had so much goodwill okay so that's
the hell I want to wrap this up could
obviously talk about this rare but the
goodwill issue and we're gonna talk
about Syria in a little bit but did we
use you know there was this feeling like
we had to get rid of Bush and Obama came
in on this wave of like ecstasy joy and
but I I'm not convinced that anyone
likes us any less or more than they did
before even though we have pulled out a
parts of world we've tried to change
some things obviously the last few weeks
a change that a little bit do you think
we stand in the in the goodwill
atmosphere and is it only Americans that
are obsessed with what everyone else
thinks in them that that I think is the
real question because i don't know the
canadians are walking around going to
say like us right after one of the
problems is that uh there's a again
there's parts of us that care about what
other other countries think of us and
there's a large percentage that don't
still don't care what other countries
think of us so I it overall with the
goodwill I think it's still Lord there's
still the perception that because of the
the disastrous not even only incall
mistakes decisions I think knowingly
decisions that were made by that
particular administration it's not
heaped on restless we're going to get to
Syria retama how Assad was talking with
Charlie Rose about well you know you
America has no no credibility anymore
remember when the colon polyp made that
speech remember George Bush this
remember when Donald Rumsfeld did that
none of those guys are in office right
now if they can continue to throw that
at us and in general I think I'm not a
world traveler but I think general
perception is yeah they're kind of
knee-jerk reaction Airy country that has
a lot of power and we need to be careful
about things that they think are going
on in that you can connect that to
anyone I mean if the way he was speaking
you would think that President Obama
launched those attacks and had Colin
Powell his secretary of state saying
those things right he has done a lot of
runs like not closing Guantanamo that
he's always said he's going to do and
the war in Afghanistan is still going on
even though that's graba so he has
continued a lot of the things that Bush
put in so that specific they talk about
things that those guys did now we've
continued but it's as if we just did
those three years ago so i think obama
stop the bleeding in a
very big way you know because it was I
think we you know we had the goodwill we
set it on fire and then we set 10 more
fires and then you know you know Obama
against end this morning or last night
he was like we're not the world police
because that's how we are perceived and
also you have all this footage
especially right after 911 when I think
one of the most horrifying sites was you
see all kinds of different countries in
the Middle East when the the world when
the second tower drop people were
screaming and clapping and so excited
about the destruction of America or part
you know whatever and they were also but
then again that the next clip is they're
holding up pieces of bombs that we have
paid for to bomb their country so it's
like you get it you understand why you
know and so and this has been since the
dawn of time us funding these militias
and these guerrilla groups to offset you
know this country's leader this
country's leader so it's like yeah it's
it is warranted that we go into all
these different countries we stick our
nose in and we and you know and we're
like our this is going to be your new
foreign policy like we I get it it's
totally understandable how people are
just certain yeah and now it was really
short now we have appointments where we
do it directly ourselves we have the
drone attacks and with again whatever I
mean you know what happened 12 years ago
we can do this now right robot to fly
yeah yeah man yeah i think it's killing
a terrorist but it's killing a whole
bunch of other people and it's a
never-ending toxic it's understandable
you